[Musica]
vi è mai capitato di guardare di
guardare una foto e non riconoscervi io
sono una fotografa e questo è il mio
strumento ma non sempre utilizzo io la
macchina per fare le fotografie circa
350 persone sono passate davanti a
questo obiettivo
dai bambini agli adulti da persone con
disagi vari
a persone che volevano lavorare su di sé
e si sono fatti un autoritratto compresa
io
tutto è nato quando mi sono trovato in
un momento di profonda crisi personale e
stato allora che ho conosciuto una
persona importante la fotografa spagnola
cristina nunez lei ha rivoluzionato il
mio modo di utilizzare la fotografia è
anche la mia visione attraverso il
metodo che lei stessa ha inventato le
self portrait experience l'esperienza
dell'autoritratto che è un modo per
esplorare la propria creatività e la
propria individualità e trasformare le
proprie emozioni in arte e io sono qua
come testimone per raccontarvi il summit
questo metodo circa il 95 per cento
degli adolescenti con cui ho lavorato ha
definito questa esperienza liberatoria
qualcuno mi ha detto questa è la foto
della vita qualcun altro mi ha detto mi
hai parto nuovi orizzonti ora so che
posso vedere anche altro nelle persone e
qualcuno mi hai detto tu non sei nulla
di me
eppure mi hai fatto una radiografia e
poi una volta è capitato che una persona
mi chiedesse ma tu sei una psicologa
no io sono una fotografa e vorrei
portarvi con me a fare un viaggio per
capire di cosa si tratta di cos'è in
cosa consiste il metodo e farlo
attraverso il mio lavoro
vi è mai capitato di essere da soli in
un set
ecco in questo caso vi lascerei da soli
in un set fotografico
io faccio l'allestimento allestisco
tutto il set secondo la mia visione
estetica e poi faccio l'inquadratura in
base anche al rapporto che si viene a
creare tra me e voi
e poi ci siete voi con il vostro
materiale grezzo le vostre emozioni
a questo punto vi chiedo di fare alcune
foto vi chiedo di cercare un emozione di
sentirla e di rappresentarla vi chiedo
di urlare silenziosamente e poi vi
chiedo di ascoltarvi perché ascoltarsi
in questo metodo è fondamentale a questo
punto vi lascio da soli ed esco fuori
dal set in pochi minuti stimolerete il
processo creativo che farà parlare
l'inconscio con il linguaggio dell'arte
rientro nel set
guardiamo le foto però vi chiederò di
guardare le foto come se stesse
guardando un'altra persona
e a questo punto nell'immagine sarete
autore colui che ha scattato soggetto
colui che nella foto e spettatore perché
vi state guardando a questo punto
andiamo alla ricerca dell'opera l'opera
è un'immagine che ha molteplici
significati spesso contrastanti tra loro
ma questi significati parlano del genere
umano parlano di qualcosa che riguarda
tutti noi che cosa vedete in questa
immagine
[Musica]
la vulnerabilità ma anche la forza e la
determinazione nel raggiungere i propri
obiettivi i bambini imparano a nominare
ea riconoscere le emozioni che gli
appartengono
il girone dell'inferno di violenti un
guerriero che urla per la vittoria e poi
tatuaggi sul suo corpo sono ancora tutta
un'altra storia
la sacralità l'adolescenza è un momento
particolarmente esplosivo di grande
ricerca e questo metodo aiuto ragazzi a
esprimersi ea poter comunicare al mondo
chi sono davvero dolore rabbia
disperazione ma se io imparo a vedere a
nominare a riconoscere ciò che mi
appartiene
allora a questo punto forse riesco a
voltare pagina e alle allora vedo forza
vedo coraggio la madre la madonna ai
piedi del cristo in croce
ogni volta che vedo questa immagine io
mi emoziono
trovo che sia estremamente molteplice
per le emozioni che comunica il suo
sguardo c'e rabbia c'è tristezza c'è
paura c'è determinazione c'è dignità e
poi è nel suo sguardo si vedono tutti i
tempi e nel passato lontano e nel futuro
lontano ed è anche qui ed ora in
profonda ricerca su di sé e toro seduto
lui sta guardando le persone sta dicendo
questo è tutto ciò che brilla e
apparenza io so che siete veramente non
mi raccontate su tutte queste sono
storie epiche che aiutano le persone a
dare significato alla propria storia ed
aiutano a vedere la grandiosità
dell'essere umano e cosa guardiamo noi
oggi quando guardiamo le foto che
abbiamo scattato
guardiamo ciò che possiamo vedere ciò
che possiamo riconoscere ciò che
possiamo acquisire possiamo vedere
qualcosa di meraviglioso che va contro
le etichette che di solito ci diamo ci
danno gli altri e la nostra dignità e la
nostra autostima aumenta e ci si può
guardare
nelle foto ci si può riconoscere e
questo metodo è un'esperienza
estremamente importante perché aiuta
alla crescita personale e anche alla
cura di sé grazie
[Applauso]